former Donald Trump advisor Roger stone
said there was possibly another case of
the FBI meddling in the Trump campaign
in 2016 in May of that year Stone says
he was approached by a man who went by
the name Henry Greenberg Greenberg
wanted to sell the Trump campaign
damaging information about Hillary
Clinton he said claimed from the
Russians Stone says he said to the man
and contemporary text back this up Trump
never pays for anything and that was it
Greenberg was apparently an FBI
informant for some number of years stone
now says he believes the entire scheme
was an effort by the FBI to set up the
Trump campaign what is the truth here
Andy McCarthy is a former assistant US
attorney for the Southern District of
New York and a contributing editor at
National Review and a very close
observer of this story he joins us
tonight Andy thanks a lot for coming on
what do you make of this story Tucker I
think it's yet another one of these
stories where you know there there's a
Russian involved so there must be
collusion or it must fit into the
narrative somehow but but it really
doesn't you know there's no linear
connection anymore to me at least to all
these stories and what the original
allegation was which was that there was
a conspiracy between the Trump campaign
and the Kremlin not just assorted
Russians ray the Russian government to
commit espionage to overturn the
election or to change the result of the
election and I think you know if there
was anything to this particular story I
mean we'll have to wait to see all the
facts come out but you know why aren't
people in handcuffs already you know why
haven't we had we've had how many people
is he charged and there's no one been
charged with any kind of a collusion
offense well no that's absolutely right
what's so odd about this though I mean
what would be the odds of a guy who
apparently really had worked for the FBI
before he cited the FBI and listed the
the cell phone number of an FBI agent in
a number of his immigration applications
so apparently he was on their payroll in
some capacity coming to the Trump
campaign offering secrets from the
Russian government unlikely the Russian
government was employing a guy who
worked for the FBI come on now and that
Muller would know about this and would
seek out the texts that
that it happened I mean what are the
odds that that's not an FBI operation
yeah well this guy apparently worked for
the FBI for 17 years according to the
reporting that we've heard and had had
supposedly according to his version of
it just ended that relationship in 2013
but in in my experience for what it's
worth they're alike officially signed up
informants and then there are right
informants who you know skulk around
listen to stuff and report back and
suddenly their informants yeah you know
so III think there's an awful lot we
have to find out about this but when I
was a prosecutor I learned not to
believe in coincidences for whatever
yeah well I stopped believing those
long-ago
this guy seemed like a skulker also for
whatever sport maybe McCarthy thank you
a trustworthy man on this topic good to
see it thanks